tu sais que quoi que je fasse cela va se
retourner contre toi et ma main je ne
veux pas qu'on vous fasse du mal depuis
les derniers jeux quelque chose a changé
je le vois qu'est ce que tu vaux
l'espoir
tu nous a sauvés je sais
mais je peux pas continuer à faire
semblant devant les caméras alors qu on
s'ignore dans la vraie vie
ils se trouvent sur elle il faut
l'éliminer
j'en conviens mais de l'abonnement
heures et au bon moment qu'on construit
et vous tu qu'arrivant youtube les gens
veulent se battre je reste ici
vous êtes bien battu mademoiselle
everdeen défi n'était que des jeux
cousturian d'affronter une fringue
imaginez des milliers de nos
compatriotes morts ce que vous aimez
disparu
qu'attendez vous de moi tanguay
les tribus seront moissonnée parmi les
précédents
démoli du rover 4
quoi je pense que ces jeux vont être
différents
ghoga
cette attaque
binetruy
g
oubliez tout ce que vous pensiez savoir
sur les jeux
l'année dernière c'était un jeu d'enfant
cette année vous n'affrontez que des
tueurs expérimente un dernier conseil à
reste en vie
n'oublie pas qu'ils aient tout véritable
est née